if you're still playing battlefield 4 I  hope you're not expecting any major  updates anytime soon the game isn't  going anywhere but according to one  battlefield producer on Twitter dice la  is finished supporting it the CTE  mentioned in the tweet is the community  test environment where dice gets  feedback on new content before it's  released to the public the CTE isn't  shutting down and the battlefield  servers are still running but it seems  dice isn't planning anything beyond  fixing small bugs and server problems  nothing is set in stone of course but  don't get your hopes up for any more  battlefield 4 map packs battlefield 4  originally launched in october 2013  which makes two and a half years of  support from dice with the team hard at  work on the next battlefield it makes  sense that they're putting all resources  into the new game so if we learn  anything about that next battlefield  game you'll hear about it on gamespot  carry on soldier